[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben so viele haben nicht
gefragt ob ich nicht einen xxl kinder
joy machen könnte und natürlich konnte
ich euch den wunsch nicht abschlagen und
hier ist es nun ein riesen kinder die
für euch damit dass kinder die auch 100%
es bleibt habe ich die plastikverpackung
in der sie typischerweise ist aus kandy
märz hergestellt
außerdem benötigen wir noch die passende
form ich habe hier eine halb iphone aus
plastik die ähnelt dem kinder die zu
100% und ich empfehle euch auch weiter
und verlinke euch dass man in die
infobox
[Musik]
da die can emails im geschmolzenen
zustand allerdings überhaupt nicht
herunter fließen und wir unbedingt diese
konzession zu brauchen
gebe ich hier noch ein wenig
geschmolzenes kokosfett mit hinzu
[Musik]
nun haben sie die perfekte konsistenz
sollten so ein wenig vom löffel herunter
fließen können und dann geht es weiter
mit der form der vorteil dieser form ist
übrigens dass der am boden abgeflacht
ist so können wir ihnen auf die
arbeitsfläche stellen ohne dass er uns
umgibt und jetzt können wir auch schon
direkt starten und geben die wärme
kennen die mails masse in die form und
spenden das hin und her
sobald die form komplett von emails
bedeckt ist können wir den überschuss
zurück in die schüssel geben mit einem
messer dann nochmal abstreifen und dann
muss das ganze einmal im kühlschrank
komplett auskühlen
[Musik]
dann wiederholt ihr den gesamten vorgang
damit die form auch stabil ist und die
wand halt nicht zu dünn ist und wenn ihr
dann noch unebenheiten habe dann
begradigt ruhig mit dem messer was auf
dem boden der form allerdings ist ist
eigentlich total unwichtig denn da kommt
später sowieso die creme hinein
[Musik]
nun geht es weiter mit den zwei kugeln
und dafür nehme ich mir hier so eine
toffifee verpackung und kleide sie mit
frischhaltefolie 1
[Musik]
anschließend nehmen wir uns waffel
blätter die findet ihr in jedem
russischen supermarkt oder auch in
grösseren supermärkten und dann nehmen
uns immer stück für stück und klein die
toffifee form damit ein
[Musik]
das ist ein bisschen fummelarbeit aber
wenn ihr das geschafft habt könnt ihr
weitermachen mit dem hotel mit der wir
dann die kügelchen befüllen ich habe sie
mir einfach in einen spritzbeutel getan
vorne die spitze abgeschnitten und jetzt
befehle ich die halbkugeln damit
[Musik]
jetzt muss sie nur noch an der
oberfläche glatt gestrichen werden denn
anschließend setzen wir immer zwei
halbkugeln zusammen und so mache ich
weiter bissig vier halbkugeln habe
es wandert jetzt zum aushärten 15
minuten lang ins gefrierfach und dann
können wir weiter machen indem wir sie
zuallererst aus der form befreien
[Musik]
nachdem wir sie dann auch von der
frischhaltefolie befreit haben wir eine
halbkugel in geschmolzene voll mit
kuvertüre und setzen sie mit der anderen
halbkugel zusammen
das gleiche tun wir dann auch mit den
anderen kugeln und dann kann das ganze
noch mal zum aushärten in den
kühlschrank
sobald die zwei hälften dann
zusammenkleben toten wir sie zuallererst
in geschmolzene förmlich kuvertüre und
anschließend in die schokostreusel
[Musik]
so sieht die erste kristallkugel nun aus
und das gleiche machen wir auch noch mit
der zweiten und jetzt geht es weiter mit
der weißen creme
dafür habe ich hier weiße kuvertüre
geschmolzen und außerdem noch gezuckerte
kondensmilch in der mikrowelle erhitzt
ganz wichtig ist dass die zwei
bestandteile auch heiß sind damit sich
gut verbinden lassen und nachdem wir
dann fleißig gerührt haben ist die weiße
film auch schon fertig
in der zwischenzeit ist unser ich sag
mal plastikteil vom kinder die schon
ausgehärtet und wir können es ganz
leicht aus der form nehmen
[Musik]
nun muss dass kinder die nur noch
befüllt werden und hierfür habe ich mir
nutella in einen spritzbeutel getan und
schneide vor allem die spitze ab
und tatsächlich ist im original kinder
die auch im unteren teil hotel da drin
und deswegen machen wir das jetzt
originalgetreu und füllen das so keller
da hinein
[Musik]
die helle creme habe ich mir ebenfalls
in einen spritzbeutel getan und vorne
die spitze abgeschnitten und gäbe dass
jetzt auch die nutella
[Musik]
mit einem löffel rücken kann man das
jetzt noch mal schön glatt streichen
damit dass auch wie im original aussieht
[Musik]
die zwei kristallkugeln gebe ich dann
noch auf die oberfläche und drücke sie
ein wenig ein
und dann ist das xxl kinder die auch
schon fertig
[Musik]
und hier zeige ich es euch auch noch mal
im vergleich also einmal das originale
kinder und meine xxl variante
[Musik]
natürlich habe ich dass kinder nicht
alleine gegessen ich hatte fleißige
helfer also aber riesenspaß gemacht das
zu essen vor allem die kugeln ja mir so
gut geschmeckt und falls jetzt auch auf
den geschmack gekommen seid und das
ganze nach machen möchtet dann schaut
doch mal in die infobox da habe ich
alles aufgeschrieben was sie dazu wissen
müsst
schaut euch auch gerne meine anderen xxl
rezepte an ich würde mich sehr freuen
wenn ihr mir ein abo dallas damit ihr
auch keines meiner videos mehr verpasst
und natürlich auch über einen daumen
nach oben
bis zum nächsten mal auf die keys
kitchen
[Musik]